ciao mariners benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video non sono pazza cielo lo vedo
anch'io l'ho fatto apposta avere
sopracciglia
insomma non truccate e perché che l'hai
fatto marina perché questo video ha un
tema importante e cioè l'evoluzione
delle mie sopracciglia negli anni e ne
vedrete delle belle
non li ho truccate appunto perché vorrei
provare insieme a voi a ricreare quei
look meravigliosi partire subito con il
primo locke key chi è stato il colpevole
di queste mie sopracciglia
ebbene sì per colpa di questa pinzetta
per le sopracciglia della quale
evidentemente ho abusato le mie
sopracciglia erano dei fili contorti
ovali un po cos'era la panda alle ciance
ricreiamo questo lupo allora erano così
all'inizio quindi dei paletti vaganti
e poi ed ecco voi questo era l'effetto
ha ovviamente rispetto a questa foto vi
volevo ricordare che ai tempi non sapevo
ancora farmi bene le foto quindi non ero
così nella vita reale ma ovviamente era
una foto presa dal basso e quindi ci
avevo sete menti quindi dopo questo look
ho iniziato ad usare delle matite
colorate del gel per sopracciglia non
ricordo esattamente il prodotto taxi
comunque di base non è che non era
cambiato molto nel senso la forma era
sempre così
cioè spin settata l'energia potenza ma
anche l'inizio del sopracciglio era
quindi rettangolino sottile e poi si
proseguiva appunto con la nostra amica
con il nostro amico arco e vuol a questo
è il risultato finale come potete vedere
è più definita di quella di prima che
era molto incolta aveva un inizio
selvaggio e una fine definita questa
invece proprio totalmente definito ma
quello che avete visto fino ad ora non è
niente in confronto a quello che state
per vedere finita la moda delle
sopracciglia sottili è iniziato il boom
delle sopracciglio le belle fault delle
spesse paladina di questo movimento e
sopracciglia cara delle vigne ovviamente
15 sono dovuti abituare gradualmente a
questo cambiamento
dico gradualmente perché adesso lo
capirete l'arco era meno profondo ma
l'attaccatura aveva effettivamente dei
problemi vi faccia subito vedere che
cosa è venuto fuori un bel rettangolo
però spesso cioè che andava anche fuori
dall'attaccatura vedete e poi andava
mano a mano a assottigliarsi quindi da
qui saliva vedete su così
il mood era questo quindi super
rettangolo nati subito fior spariva per
lasciare il posto a questa fantastica
questo vada sicko filino ma anche qui mi
sono è voluta perché il rettangolo ha
iniziato ad allungarsi d'angolo né lungo
tutto colorato dentro ovviamente effetto
proprio fake
poi però c'era sempre quel momento in
cui il rettangolo decideva di diventare
un filo cioè vedete come si è evoluto
questo sono cilione di marina
qui era esattamente il doppio promesso
che guardo bene non era neanche non
andrà neanche giù così era po più ferma
a mezz'aria mi piace dopo anni e anni di
sopracciglia tremende finalmente ho
intravisto la luce ora visto la luce
perché ho imparato innanzitutto a non
martoriarlo con la pinzetta e poi
soprattutto ho scoperto dei prodotti
meravigliosi per le sopracciglia che
sono quelli che si usano da anni secoli
più o meno
in particolare oggi utilizzerò il brown
styler di benefit che un nuovissimo
prodotto con due prodotti 2 in 1 anzi
tre perché tra perché da un lato c'è la
matita in cera dall'altro c'è una
polvere libera che fatica perché va a
riempire tutti i buchini da un effetto
molto molto naturale ma possono essere
anche utilizzati insieme quindi si può
dare un terzo effetto per appunto vedere
sopra più gold con la mia matita in cera
vado a definire il sopracciglio e molto
comodo perché appunto avendo questa
forma è perfetto anche per l'angolo
vedete qui senza troppa fatica andate a
disegnare il vostro angolo
una volta definite bene le vostre
sopracciglia di io amo mettere anche la
polvere libera come vedete da un effetto
supernatural e ma riempire bene di tutti
i bambini
poi per enfatizzare appunto era nostra
casa o applicate del correttore
picchiettando lo molto poco giusto per
dare appunto questa luminosità oppure
dell'illuminante vendono anche delle
matite appunto apposta per sopracciglia
così andate a illuminare di più quel
quella zona ea rendere il vostro spazio
ancora più fatemi sapere con un commento
qui sotto
tra quali di questi look tremendi a
parte l'ultimo ovviamente vi siete
ritrovati nel senso che obiettivamente
ci siamo passati un po tutte quindi mi
raccomando mandatemi magari anche le
vostre foto in direct ovviamente
rimarranno tra me e voi non le
pubblicherò giusto per condividere
queste disgrazie che ci hanno accumulato
se invece volete saperne di più sul
browser di benefit mi lascio qui sotto
il link con tutti i dettagli
io vi mando un bacione mi raccomando
seguitemi su instagram nei tic toc
perché ovviamente sto postando
tantissimi contenuti anche lì e ci
vediamo al prossimo video
ciao da me e dai miei sopracciglia top
[Musica]